greasy pizza fries cookies that's what
school lunches are made of right well
not so much anymore school lunches are
changing thanks to the Healthy
hunger-free Kids Act it was enacted into
US law this year law requires ninety
seven thousand American public schools
to provide healthier food well in theory
it's supposed to mean more fruits and
veggies less saturated fats less salt
Greg Hughes right well the food industry
doesn't seem to think so
companies like Kellogg's and coca-cola
have spent millions of dollars trying to
prevent these changes and here's the
kicker food lobbyists were actually
involved in crafting the legislation
itself and when you actually read the
bill itself you'll find that it's not
really a complete overhaul of school
lunch health standards but still the big
food industry is fighting the changes
and turning school cafeterias into a
political food fight the first lady
Michelle Obama is making kids health a
priority and has championed the new
legislation lawmakers across the country
seemed to be on board but just as the
program was being rolled out this year
Republican lawmakers have been trying to
roll it back in they pushed to allow
certain schools to opt out of making
these changes to their cafeteria menus
but why do they want kids to be fat like
big oil and big pharma there's big food
and one of their biggest consumers kids
big food has a dedicated team of
lobbyists and cash to influence
Washington leaders and they concentrate
their money on members that serve the US
Department of Agriculture who decide the
nation's food policy that translates to
millions of dollars in lobbying so is
surprise that big food has used its
lobbyists to try to shape the guidelines
of the Healthy hunger-free Kids Act and
it's also targeted the school nutrition
Association or the SNA to try to push
back the SNA board should have been the
program's natural allies and initially
they were but now they're amongst the
most vocal critics leading a lobbying
campaign to allow schools to opt out of
following the guidelines maybe it's
because they're backed by food industry
heavyweights like Domino's Pizza and
Pepsi in fact just about half of the SNA
s ten million dollar budget comes from
big food for big food childhood obesity
is less important than profits and the
ever revolving door that sums up
Washington DC doesn't help just last
month a leading former PepsiCo lobbyist
named Joel left which was named chief of
staff of the Senate agricultural
committee that's the same agricultural
committee that does regular overhauls of
different nutrition programs including
the Healthy hunger-free Kids Act and his
former employer Pepsi has been key in
fighting local soda taxation and
ensuring junk food remains available at
schools so how is all of this happening
how does this have so much say in our
kids diets well we've got separation of
church and state in this country but
corporations and state